première visite en France du jeune
président tunisien Ben Ali le successeur
d'Habib bourgiba à la tête du pays
depuis près d'un an cette visite d'État
est destinée à resserrer les liens entre
la Tunisie et la France on devrait
aborder un certain nombre de dossiers
concernant nos deux pays coopération
économique culturelle et de défense
Hélène
rizacher en ce moment même dîner de gala
à l'Élysée offert par le président
mitteran en l'honneur du président Ben
Ali les deux hommes ont tu premier
entretien en tête- à-tête cet après-midi
cette visite est la première du
président Ben Ali dans un pays non arabe
et tout sera fait pour qu'elle marque la
fin du flottement franco-tunisien
objectif élargir la coopération entre
les deux pays en matière de défense un
projet de couverture radar de la Tunisie
dans le domaine audiovisuel éventuelle
diffusion en Tunisie d'une chaîne
française grand public au chapitre
international des deux côtés ont met en
avant les contacts entre l'Europe et le
Grand Maghreb les bonnes relations entre
Paris et Tunis pourraient servir de
moteur pour resserer les liens entre ces
deux communautés ce grand Maghreb
souhaité par le président Ben Ali ne va
pas selon lui sans une Tunisie forte
officiellement c'est pour redresser la
barre que le général Ben Ali Premier
ministre décida de prendre le pouvoir le
7 novembre
87 conformément à la Constitution il dém
Habib bourgiba de la présidence pour
sénilité médicalement reconnue depuis le
président Ben Ali incarne le changement
dans le pays il ouvre le débat politique
consulte l'opposition et commence à en
légaliser les organisations objectif
installer le tipartisme en Tunisie avec
un Paris désamorcé les attaques des
islamistes pour le symbole Benali se
rend à la MEC du même coup il rassure
les Tunisiens attachés à leur foi puis
des contacts sont pris avec les
intégristes du mouvement de la tendance
islamique le président Ben Ali a proposé
un pacte national au pays pour assurer
la démocratie des élections
présidentielles au suffrage universel et
des législatives anticipées sont prévues
pour le 7 novembre